man streitet immer noch in den USA
Demokraten mit den Republikanern Europa
hat bis heute gestritten im Worte sind
alle immer für die Ukraine und dann
denkt man am Ende doch mehr an sich
selbst ja und auch die das Ergebnis von
heute ist natürlich ein gutes Ergebnis
für Europa aber jetzt sollten wir uns
nicht zu heftig auf die eigene Schulter
klopfen äh diese 40 Milliarden sind 0,8
Promill der europäischen
Wirtschaftsleistung verteilt auf 4er
Jahre mhm das ist ein dringend
notwendige Geldspritze aber bei weitem
nicht das was man feiern könnte weil
die die Ukraine uns ja nicht anlügt die
sind tatsächlich in bitterer not was
ihre Ausstattung angeht und es ist nur
dem weitgehenden Versagen der russischen
Armee zu verdanken dass die Sache nicht
viel viel schlimmer im Moment aussieht
für die Ukraine und die Mittel die wir
dann aufwenden müssen
sollte man jetzt nicht sparsam
zurückhalten sondern das ist das
notwendige jetzt Manfred Weber EVP
Vorsitzender im Europäischen Parlament
sie waren erweber letzte Woche in Kiev
und
haben nicht nur den Präsidenten selenski
getroffen aber auch ihn was sagt er
ihnen hinter den
Kameras ja zunächst mal sind wir am
Dienstag an einen Tag angekommen ich mit
meiner Delegation wo Raketen den Boden
erreicht haben wo die Luft tow auch
unterstützt durch Deutschland die G
Panzer die Patriot Systeme eben nicht
alle Raketen abgefangen haben wir sind
im Kriegsgebiet angekommen und das ist
zunächst mal bedrückend bedrückend zu
sehen wie die Menschen auch diese
Normalität mittlerweile leben zwei Jahre
in diesem Wahnsinn zu leben
m und
die Bilder die ich mitnehme die
Stimmungen die ich mitnehme ist
Entschiedenheit ist der Wille diesen
Kampf zu gewinnen für die eigene
Freiheit für die eigene Demokratie zu
streiten was sagen sie hinter den
Kameras wie dringend brauchen Sie uns
unsere Hilfe wie leergeschossen sind sie
schon dieses Wort hat mich allein beim
Lesen erschüttert Russland setzt hat
jetzt bei dertillerie über Übermacht sie
setzen täglich 7000 Schuss ein die
Ukrainer müssen mittlerweile die
Artilleriemunition rationieren setzen
2000 Schuss ein deswegen haben wir an
der Front diese Gewichte Verschiebung
das heißt die erste Botschaft war
Munition Munition Munition bitte helft
uns endlich und das zweite die zweite
große Botschaft war und das war für mich
auch positiv zu sehen selenski ist
wichtig dass wir die Davos Initiative er
ne er spricht über Diplomatie er spricht
darüber dass seine Friedensinitiative
sein zehn Punkteplan dass dafür wirbt
dass wir global auch im globalen Süden
ist ja ganz Frage ganz große Frage der
Machtpolitik weltweit jetzt dass wir
Partner finden die sich um Frieden
bemühen und dieser Zweiklang Waffen aber
gleichzeitig diplomatie ist das was ich
mitgenommen habe und was Europa jetzt
auch anpacken muss Marie AGN Star
Zimmermann ist bei uns FDP Politikerin
und für die FDP nun auch im
Europawahlkampf Frau Stck Zimmermann die
dieser Streit zwischen den deutschen und
den Franzosen wer jetzt mehr beigetragen
hat zu der zu den Hilfslieferungen an
die Ukraine da schüttelt man doch
eigentlich nur noch den Kopf und sagt
große Sorgen kleines Caro na ja es ist
so dass in der Tat Deutschland was sich
ja sehr schwer getan hat am Anfang wir
erinnern uns an die helmdebatte wirklich
eine Menge macht und sehr deutsch erst
streiten diskutieren und wenn wir was
machen machen was gut gar keine Frage
dass wir außerordentlich viel tun das
reicht aber nicht es ist auch die
richtig dass es keine bilaterale Frage
ist wir haben 27 EU-Staaten die ja
gerade in den ersten Monaten auch so
zusammengestanden haben dass Putin sich
die Augen gerieben hat weil er es nicht
glaubte Putin hat aber auch immer wieder
gesagt seine Zeitfrage er kennt Europa
er kennt natürlich auch die Schwäche
einer Demokratie nämlich konsequent
dabei zu bleiben das hat auch was mit
innerem Druck zu tun dass eben auch in
den Ländern gesagt wird was passiert da
und insofern ich verstehe dass der
Kanzler sehr deutlich darauf hinweist ob
das mit einem Brief getan ist wage ich
mal zu bezweif sie kommen jetzt schon
auf diesen öffentlichen Brief der
Bundeskanzler hat muss man sagen einen
öffentlichen Brief geschrieben
unterschrieben noch von vier anderen
Kollegen und hat damit im Grunde
genommen und hat gebeten mehr zu tun zu
drängen und hat damit im Grunde etwas
gemacht was sie sonst immer machen
nämlich in der Öffentlichkeit
kritisieren und drängen ist das immer
der gute weg ich mach das ich mache das
indem ich keine Briefe schreibe ich
glaube man kann das auch artikulieren es
lenngt natürlich ein bisschen davon ab
dass Deutschland noch mehr machen könnte
okay und da sind wir auch in der
Relation zu dem was wir leisten können
lenken wir natürlich auch jetzt oder
lenkt der kannz natürlich auch ein
bisschen jetzt davon ab von der
innerdeutschen Debatte wo eben auch sehr
schon seit langen seit 7 a Monaten
gefordert wird eben auch den Taurus zu
liefern das ist kein gamechanger aber er
würde zumindest Probleme den Russen
kritisiert um nicht kritisiert zu werden
sagen sie na ich würde zumindest sagen
dass ja in der Politik nichts
ungewöhnlich ist dass man auch mal
ablenkt von der von der eigenen internen
Diskussion und darauf hinweist dass die
anderen mehr machen müssen aber um Ihre
Frage zu beantworten ähm die Franzosen
ich hatte gerade am Montag den
Verteidigungsausschuss Frankreichs da
die rechnen das einfach anders die sagen
wir haben eine Menge in der sahilzone
gemacht wir haben eine Forste frapp also
sozusagen da werden jetzt wird jetzt
viel zusammengeworfen und es ist richtig
wir müssen deutlich mehr tun und das
muss man auch fordern und wir haben
überhaupt keine Zeit und Wladimir Putin
lebt weiß natürlich noch mal dass äh wir
eben in einer Phase sind wo jetzt die
internen Diskussionen beginnen und das
auch noch öffentlich kann man in der
Demokratie nicht ganz verhindern ein
fatales Zeichen und dass die EU ja
eigentlich von einer Millionen Schuss
gesprochen hat jetzt ist es deutlich
weniger ähm das hat viele Gründe aber
das macht natürlich der Ukraine keinen
Mut es ist peinlich dass wir das nicht
schaffen und jetzt Ende des Jahres
ankündigen und diese eine Millionen
Schuss nicht zusammenkriegen schaffen
wir Ende des Jahres würde also ich würde
ich würde nicht sagen dass es peinlich
ist erstmal dass die EU in der Lage war
gemeinsam so etwas zu formulieren äh und
sich auf den Weg zu machen finde ich mal
grundsätzlich was tolles das war nämlich
vor Jahren unvorstellbar okay dass es
weniger geworden ist liegt auch
schlichtweg daran wahrscheinlich hat man
da auch zu groß gedacht dass natürlich
die Industrie angesichts dessen dass ja
über Jahre gar nichts eingekauft wurde
also nichts relevantes jetzt die
Kapazitäten hochfahren muss und ein
kurzes Beispiel Munition wir blicken
jetzt mal nach trostdorf das ist bei
Köln wo also jetzt auch Bürgermeister
gefordert sind zu sagen da ist eine
Munitionsfabrik die will erweitern schon
seit Monaten kriegt die Erlaubnis der
Stadt nicht kann aber jetzt nicht
woanders die Zelte aufschlagen heißt
dass diese Zeitenwende dass diese
Ernsthaftigkeit wirklich runtergebrochen
werden muss auch in die kleinste gemind
werden mus in der Tat und auch im Land
verstanden werden muss Frank sauer ist
bei uns Sicherheitsexperte Uni München
bundeswehruni wollte ich unbedingt noch
dazu sagen solange Deutschland müssen
wir sie Fragen wollen wir sie fragen
solange Deutschland den Taurus nicht
liefert äh wird dieses Land in den Augen
der anderen ein Bremser sein ne das
glaube ich nicht also grundsätzlich ist
es schon richtig was Frau strzmann
gesagt hat Deutschland macht sehr viel
ich glaube nicht unbedingt dass wir
zwangsläufig als Bremser dar stehen wir
sind ja in absoluten Zahlen in dieser
Gruppe aus 50 Staaten die sogenannte
Ukraine Kontaktgruppe die der Ukraine
helfen sind ja in absoluten Zahlen so
auf Platz 2 hinter den USA wir sind
allerdings gemessen am brutto
Inlandsprodukt das muss man auch der
Ehrlichkeit halber dazu sagen auf Platz
14 ne also es gibt natürlich Mittel und
osteuropäische Staaten baltische Staaten
die viel mehr gemacht haben kleiner sind
aber trotzdem viel mehr gemacht haben in
der Vergangenheit die sich quasi blank
gemacht haben an ein paar Punkten
und das muss man sozusagen in G in Gänze
Betrachten der Taurus unser
verteiligungsminister pistorus ist ja
schon genervt von der Debatte kann man
se die Debatte Leid sie helfen uns bei
der Beantwortung der Frage was an dieser
an diesem Ringtausch jetzt dran ist also
wir sollen angeblich Taurus den Briten
liefern damit die Briten dann weiter
stormshadow in die Ukraine liefern nur
dann hätte die Ukraine keine Taurus
richtig es ist ein insgesamt
suboptimales Ergebnis was dabei
rauskommt weil also die Ukraine kriegt
mehr marlukörper das ist gut aber sie
kriegt eben nicht Taurus sondern die die
sie schon hat gut besser als nichts ja
aber sie bräuchte eigentlich den Taurus
aus Gründen auf die wir vielleicht
gleich noch kommen können und so ein
bisschen kurios an der ganzen Sache ist
auch wenn dieser Ringtausch mit
Großbritannien dann wirklich stattfinden
sollte dass der Taurus auf dem
Eurofighter eigentlich gar nicht
einsetzbar ist und nur mit dem verbracht
werden kann den die Briten schon lange
nicht mehr fliegen also kurz gesagt die
Ukrainer kriegen nicht den marslugkörper
den sie wirklich gerne hätten den sie
eigentlich auch sehr gut gebrauchen
könnten und die Briten bekommen ein Mar
Körper den sie nicht benutzen können
also ja aber es wird nicht stattfinden
da hat einer ein Ballon losgelassen und
der ist schon auf dem Weg nach oben
geplatzt man hört auch schon länger
nichts mehr davon ja hat auch keiner
wirklich bes wir versuchen das auch
gleich noch mal zu verstehen was da
jetzt wirklich der Grund ist warum wir
wieder zögern das machen wir aber erst
nachdem wir unbedingt urula Schröder
Politikwissenschaftlerin bei uns begrüßt
haben sie ist Direktorin des Instituts
für Friedensforschung und
Sicherheitspolitik an der Uni Hamburg
für die Ukraine sieht es gerade nicht
gut aus sie hat nicht nur diese letzte
Offensive nicht für sich entschieden
sondern ihr geht offensichtlich eben
auch wirklich materialgerät und Soldaten
aus
werden noch mehr Waffen an dieser
Situation etwas entscheidend ern Frau
Schreuder ja die Frage ist was dazu noch
kommen muss ich was wir sehen ist dass
die Ukraine in einem in einem
strategischen Limbo relativ alleine
gelassen wird weil selbst mehr
Waffenlieferungen nicht ersetzen dass
sich die westliche Allianz stärker und
langfristiger verpflichten muss
politisch militärisch und ökonomisch zu
unterstützen
weil die Ukraine gar nicht weiß auf
welcher Basis sie gerade handeln kann
weil sie nicht weiß auf was sie sich
verlassen kann und was wow das ist ein
super interessanter Punkt das heißt die
Ukraine hat noch nie von den westlichen
Partnern irgendein versprechen bekommen
was die Zukunft betrifft also wie weit
unsere Sicherheitsmaßnahmen gingen das
ist ja der Kern auf dem Weg zu einer
Beendigung dieses langandauernden
Krieges die noch in weiter Ferne sein
wird ist ja die Frage welche Form von
Sicherheitsgarantien wird die Ukraine
bekommen wer wird diese unterschreiben
wie können wir über das Dilemma
hinwegkommen dass die Ukraine irgendwann
wieder mit einem russischen g
sich an einen Tisch setzen werden muss
bei dem sie nicht daran glauben kann
dass geschlossene Abkommen eingehalten
werden das muss von außen garantiert
werden da kommen die
Sicherheitsgarantien rein das muss
wirtschaftlich unterfüttert werden das
muss politisch gestaltet werden und wir
reden die ganze Zeit nur über
militärische Systeme die sind wichtig
das sagen wir auch in der
Friedensforschung aber der größere
Rahmen das politische Ziel das ist etwas
das würde ich gerne deutlicher in der
Debatte sehen
ja Herr Weber das ist interessant
natürlich auch was sind wir bereit als
als Westen eben der Ukraine zu
garantieren in einem Zeitraum danach
wenn man den westlichen Staaten jetzt so
zugeschaut hat die letzten zwei Jahre
brauchten die Entscheidungen ja immer
sehr sehr lange die Frage ist eigentlich
noch mal was erwartet die Ukraine
eigentlich wenn Sie uns so zuschaut in
unserem bisherigen entscheiden und da
ist natürlich wirklich wichtig zu wissen
was würde Europa denn tun und der
Ukraine anbieten können die Ukraine
kämpft Ukrainer sterben derzeit für ihre
für ihr Land und für ihre Werte die sie
hochhalten und deswegen wenn wir uns an
Tisch die Frage stellen was erwarten sie
dann warten Sie einfach Unterstützung s
warten schnelle Unterstützung und
keinchuldigung das harte Wort zu
verwenden kein zynisches wir geben so
viel dass ihr nicht gewinnen könnt aber
auch nicht so wenig dass ihr verliert
das Gefühl ist manchmal da auch in der
Ukraine deswegen geht's um die
Fragestellung stehen wir zu dem wovon
wir überzeugt sind und das wird jetzt
leider aufgrund des der Brutalität von
Putin der deutsche Botschafter in
Ukraine in in Kiev hat mir erzählt dass
derzeit zwischen 4 und 800 Russen jeden
Tag an der Front sterben mit dieser mit
dieser menschenverachtenden putinpitik
hat die Ukraine jeden Tag zu tun und in
der Situation kann es nur einen Weg
geben nämlich die Ukraine zu stärken so
schnell wie möglich zu stärken und da
waren wir Deutschen wir leisten heute
viel aber wir waren natürlich schon
immer zu langsam und ein Stück weit zu
wenig in all diesen in dies Sendung wenn
Sie laauben einen Punkt noch zu Europa
allein lassen ich glaube wenn jetzt im
Dezember die europäische Union ein Land
im Krieg die Zusage gibt ihr dürft
Mitglied der EU werden ihr dürft
Mitglied unserer Gemeinschaft werden ist
es für die Ukrainer ein gewaltiges
Symbol es lohnt sich zu kämpfen dass ihr
auch so leben dürft wie Slowaken Leben
wie Ungarn Leben wie
rum sind Themen die für die Psychologie
in der Ukraine extrem wichtig waren und
der heutige Tag mit dem 50 Milliarden da
reden wir ja nicht über Waffen da reden
wir über die Krankenschwester Dred wir
über den den Lehrer der bezahlt wird
also wir und schützen uns damit übrigens
vor neuen Flüchtlingen wenn wir die
keit erhalten zu können weil die
Menschen draußen natürlich nur die 50
Milliarden hören jetzt gibt wieder Geld
aus und so wir müssen sagen es ist unsum
tiefen Interesse das zu machen wir sind
nicht Kriegspartei heute aber ich sage
ausdrücklich wir sind Kriegsziel aus
Putins Sicht und das müssen wir immer
wieder deutlich die Ukrainer konnten
sich eben in nicht immer EU ich weiß da
gibt's auch noch einen guten Hinweis auf
natürlich auch die Paragraphen und die
Verf der Europäischen Union und trotzdem
ist es wichtig zu sagen worin bestüen
denn unsere militärischen Garantien für
das
Land Herr selenski wenn man ihm
aufmerksam zugehört hat Frau Stag
Zimmermann hat er den Bundeskanzler also
Olaf Scholz gar nicht gescholten für den
Taurus sondern er hat gesagt er hat
Verständnis der Herr Scholz konnte das
nicht allein entscheiden wer anders als
die Amerikaner könnte gemeint sein durch
ihn nein ich glaube dass herrelenski
natürlich ein kluger Mann ist er braucht
die Unterstützung
und es wäre ja schlecht dem Unterstützer
vors Knie zu treten also das wäre
äußerst ungeschickt zumal Herr Scholz ja
auch dazu neigt eher bockig zu sein wenn
man ihn unter Druck setzt die Frage ist
ja die auch immer wieder kolpotiert wird
dass alles sehr eng mit den Amerikanern
abgestimmt wird wenn sie aber in den
Vereinigten Staaten sind und da war ich
vor kurzem und sie sprechen dort mit den
Entscheidern auch mit dem
Sicherheitsberater des Präsidenten und
sie sprechen unter anderem die Frage des
Taurus an dann sagt er let's go also
sich zurück üzuziehen das andere grünes
Licht geben so kommt man aus der Nummer
nicht raus aber die Amerikaner haben
lange gezögert diese berühmten attackems
zu schicken sie haben 40 der älteren
Modelle den Ukrainern übersand auch die
Amerikaner haben gezögert auch das ist
ja nachgewiesen ja weil weil das
natürlich noch mal das ist die
Vereinigten Staaten sind jetzt im
Wahlkampf auch dort muss man erklären
was passiert da gerade und insofern ist
natürlich jedes Land innenpolitisch
sozusagen getrieben es ändert aber
nichts daran dass die Vereinigten
Staaten sich nicht gemüsigt fühlen uns
immer grünes Licht zu geben wir können
da sehr selbstbewusst als sehr großes
wohlhabendes Land wurde ja auch gerade
gesagt können wir da ruhig in die
Führung gehen und deswegen werden die
Amerikaner den Teufel Ton den daumen
rauf oder runter zusetzen also in meiner
Gegenwart war völlig klar macht es man
muss auch immer wieder sagen das ist
jetzt kein gamechanger das jetzt hier
alles völlig neu aufgerollt wird aber es
ist eine Methode um das diese Ziele zu
zerstören oder besser gesagt den Angriff
zu zerstören von dem wir einfach wissen
dass dort jeden Tag Raketen abgeschossen
werden und dazu ist der Taurus mal
entwickelt worden noch zu Warschauer
Pakt natozeiten und das wirklich dove
ist dass das jetzt so ein Politikum
geworden ist also die ganze
Bundesrepublik spricht plötzlich über
ein Waffensystem die haben natürlich
recht da gibt's noch viel anderes über
was wir diskutieren müssen also ein
Waffensystem und dadurch ist das jetzt
völlig verhärtet äh und das ist
bedauerlich weil wie gesagt wir haben
genug wir könnten ein teil aber warum
hat Herr selenski mehr Verständnis für
den Bundeskanzler als sie sie sagen Herr
selenski möchte beide seit ich brauch
den den Taurus nicht um zu überleben
Herr selenski weiß genau das Thema
Munition das Thema was noch gebraucht
wird die Wirtschaft am Laufen zu halten
humanitäre Hilfe die Fragen der
Diplomatie was kann man noch machen wie
gesagt er wird Herr selenski wird nicht
auf ein Waffensystem sich reduzieren das
wäre auch ein bisschen schwal aber die
Frage muss natürlich sein wir haben von
einer panzerkoalition gesprochen von
einer F16 Koalition es ist ja nicht dass
das alles jetzt ständig die Ukraine
erreichen aber was ist an dem Taurus
dran ja dass der Kanzler so bockig
geworden ist mit dem Taus dass er da
eigentlich politisch gar nicht mehr
runterkommt ist die Frage die Herr Sauer
gleich beantwortet ich würde vorher
gerne von von dir noch wissen warum die
Amerikaner eigentlich zögern warum sind
auch den warum kann man auch den
Amerikanern nachweisen dass sie nicht
ihr best und toollstes Gerät geliefert
haben das wäre ja auch zu tun ja und
dann haben sie Panzer geliefert die
eigentlich für diesen Krieg gar nicht
geeignet sind um zu zeigen wir bringen
das modernste größte teuerste schwerste
ja und als Bedingung weil Leopard kommt
nur wenn die Amerikaner
ih also ich manches entzieht sich
vernünftiger Beurteilung also da sind
symbolkriege entstanden und ich versuche
zu verstehen was für ein selenski der
nicht Symbole braucht zwischendurch
helfen die auch aber im Grunde braucht
er die Hardware und dann muss er sich
auf symboldebatten zuschauen beschränken
als der Mann der wirklich die politische
Verantwortung trägt für das was seinen
Bürgern passiert immer Moment es ist ja
eben auch deutlich
ausgesprochen worden die Kritik es ist
gesagt worden von Joe Biden dass
russisches Territorium nicht erreicht
werden soll es ist gesagt worden äh dass
Russland natürlich als Land nicht
vernichtet werden soll es ist gesagt
worden dass die ukrainische Strategie
nicht so schlau ist das wird jetzt nicht
bei dem Taurus entscheidend sein aber
ist ist es eine Mischung aus russisches
Territorium soll nicht erreicht werden
Ukrainer sollen nicht zu sehr Siegen ja
also es ist natürlich sehr vernünftig
darauf zu achten dass Putin keine Treppe
hingestellt wird mit einer nächsten
Eskalationsstufe auf J du noch
draufreten muss das ist schon klug und
sinnvoll dieser Krieg muss als laufender
Krieg auch
contained eingehegt werden aber wenn das
das All oberste Ziel ist und die Ukraine
dabei unter die Räder kommt und die
Menschen dort
auch erschöpft sind mehr als ich vor
ziemlich genau einem Jahr in in in Kiev
war war ich wahnsinnig beeindruckt von
ganz normalen Menschen und die haben
absoluten durchhalte Willen die auch
cool das alles ertragen haben was sie
Herr Weber gerade gchrieben
Unerschrockenheit haben ja so aufrecht
und unerschrocken waren junge Leute auch
junge Leute die wussten ich werde jetzt
demnächst eingezogen mhm und ich bin
nicht abgehauen in den Westen sondern
ich bin hier geblieben weil ich
gebraucht werde ähm aber irgendwann
erschöpft sich das ähm insbesondere wenn
du spürst meine großen Freunde die sehr
mächtig sind ähm arbeiten mit einer Hand
in der Hosentasche und machen das nur so
Hal die Fragestellung ob wir Putin
provozieren nicht der Maßstab sein
deswegen würde ich mir vom Bundeskanzler
erwarten dass er begründet warum Taurus
nicht geliefert genau diese Begründung
wird ja nicht geliefert es wird nur
gesagt das machen wir nicht ja
vielleicht um takchzutreten und ich
vorher bescheben mit dem durchaus
zynischen dabei das jetzt also jetzt mit
nicht liefern nicht mit nicht voller
Unterstützung eher den Krieg verlängern
werden das was helfen würde W
Entschiedenheit wäre so entscheidend
anders wenn der Taurus käme irgendetwas
muss besonderes in seinen Fähigkeiten
sein wir lesen verschiedenstes wir lesen
dass
es eine besondere Reichweite gibt was
wahrscheinlich nicht stimmt weil die
Reichweite haben ja programmiert ja auch
niedrigere Reichweiten Programmier e die
Amerikaner haben ihre attackems gedimmt
die konnten gar nicht so weit fliegen
wie sie eigentlich sollten es wird
gesagt dass deutsche Soldaten in die
Ukraine müssten um es wird da schütteln
Sie schon
den was sind die Gründe für die
Zurückhaltung also mich nervt ja die
taurusdebatte auch eigentlich will ich
sie tatsächlich nicht führen ich ich
will sozusagen deswegen eine Sache
voranschieben und dann beantworten all
die Fragen wäre toll m es ist
tatsächlich so dass viele Dinge waren
eben dadurch zu erklären dass wir uns in
2022 vorgetest vorgetastet haben da
sollte man vielleicht auch nicht zu sehr
hingehen und sagen wir wissen es jetzt
heute alles besser und so ich denke halt
nur dass die Lernkurve ist zu flach ja
also wir hatten quasi die Mischung macht
wir hatten quasi ein Verhältnis von
Entschlossenheit zu besondenheit von 40
zu 60 man müsste es umdrehen wir müssten
bisschen entschlossener rangehen und die
Besonderheit können wir bisschen
runterfahren weil wir haben ja vieles
geliefert und es ist nichts passiert es
ist nicht eskaliert bzw es eskaliert
aber die Zivilbevölkerung trägt ja
sozusagen
die Last dessen und insofern sollten wir
auch im Zuge dessen weg von dieser
einzelwaffeniskussion ja also ich bin
vollkommen bei Frau Schröder wir müssten
eigentlich viel stärker mal in so eine
größere strategische aktive Diskussion
und nicht immer nur reagieren jetzt
geben wir einen Waffensystem dann dann
machen wir erstmal 80 Millionen
expertinen und Experten für dieses eine
Waffensystem aber das ist interessant
immer also auch das ist ja jetzt so eine
Welle den Medien vorzuhalten dass wir
immer nur einzelne Waffenkategorien
besprochen hätten nee das werfe ich
nicht zwingend den Meden ich will ja
auch gar nicht sagen dass ich mir sofort
die Jacke anziehe ich will nur sagen
offensichtlich war das ja dearly needed
und die Ukraine hat sehr also es war
erbeten und die Ukraine hat sehr darum
gerungen und wir konnten so schlecht
erklären warum wir es nicht gleich zur
Verfügung stellten jetzt der Taurus was
ist das für ein zauberding und was
glauben Sie warum wir so zurückhalten
also es ist kein zauberding es ist ein
marchflugkörper es ist ein sehr
wirkmächtiges Waffensystem aber das
haben wir auch schon gehört es ist im
Grunde kalte kriegstechnologie und es
ist richtig diese Passage in diesem
Interview mit Herrn selenski war extrem
interessant als diese Thematik aufkam
weil da schon sehr stark laviert hat mhm
und die Hypothesen die dann aufgestellt
wurden waren natürlich zweierlei wen
meint er wenn er sagt Olaf Scholz
entscheidet es nicht alleine wer sind
die großen anderen Staaten irgendwi sind
die USA so und dann gab's zwei
hypothesenesagt es hat irgendwas mit
Militärtechnik zu tun kurz gesagt in
diesem Taurus marsl Körper ist irgendwas
drin an Technologie was da besser nicht
runterfällt und vielleicht in russische
Hände wertvolles geh würden wir auch
nicht zum ersten Mal hören genau und die
andere Passage wäre halt zu sagen es hat
irgendwie politischen Hintergrund diese
technische Sache kann ich nach meinem
Kenntnisstand also weitestgehend
ausschließen ich da ist natürlich ein
amerikanisches Triebwerk drin aber das
wissen alle und darin ist auch keine
zaubertechnologie vor all wenn das der
Grund wäre könnte man ja nichts mehr
einsetzen genau also den kann man mal
beiseite lassen und dann wäre die andere
Überlegung dann gibt's einen politischen
Grund das ist ja das was wir jetzt
besprochen haben die beiden
Administrationen zumindest Teile der
Administration war eben auch sehr stark
auf dieser Linie zu schauen
Eskalationsmanagement und da wäre eben
sozusagen die Logik hat beiden zu Scholz
gesagt mit dem Taurus mal warten der hat
bestimmte Fähigkeiten die vielleicht ein
Schritt zu weit gehen auch dieses
Argument muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen
wird immer schwächer im Lichte dessen
was wir beobachten ja alsoackams wurde
dann geliefert wenn gleich auch nur mit
diesem
klastermunitionssprengkopf aber jetzt
ist ja auch die ground launched small
diameter bomb es tut mir sehr leid wir
reden wieder über Waffensysteme aber die
sozusagen auch eine weitreichende Waffe
sag ich mal ganz einfach von den USA
geliefert und das geht ja offensichtlich
auch ja also so richtig ist nicht klar
was der Punkt ist und das Einzige was
den Taurus wirklich stark unterscheidet
von Storm Shadow und skalalp also den
britischen und den französischen
marlkörpern die die Ukraine schon hat
und einsetzt ist nicht unbedingt die
Reichweite ja die ist etwas größer das
stimmt aber der spenkopf also der Taurus
kann etwas was diese anderen beiden
nicht können und ich vereinfache das
jetzt drastisch der kann erkennen durch
was er gerade durchfliegt wenn er ein
Ziel trifft und er kann zählen welche
Schichten von Beton z.B er schon
durchschlagen hat so und der Punkt ist
dabei natürlich damit kann ich etwas
machen was diese anderen beiden nicht
können oder nur mit sehr viel Glück da
muss ich quasi die Zeit einstellen und
abschätzen wann er explodieren soll mhm
der kann die kerchbrücke zerstören die
Brücke von K muss man noch mal ganz kurz
sagen kurz vor der krimp Versorgung
genau der würde eben der würde quasi
zählen jetzt bin ich durch die Fahrbahn
durch jetzt bin ich durch die Betondecke
das ist der Betonpfeiler da explodiere
ich und deswegen wäre es tatsächlich aus
meiner Perspektive drinkt notwendig
dieses Waffensystem an die gameanger und
es wäre ein gamechanger weil ja also ich
benutze dieses Wort nicht mit diesem
gamechanger ich halte es inzwischen für
se W das Game gechanged es wäre es wäre
eine sehr willkommene Fähigkeit für die
Ukraine so weil wir natürlich auch schon
verstanden haben dass wenn die Ukraine
die Krim zurückerobern würde Frau ST
Zimmermann dann wäre das war ja so eine
what if Rechnung dann wäre die
landversorgung für Russland quasi
unmöglich und dann hätte Putin auch
einen in Anführungsstrichen
nachvollziehbaren Grund doch mal ganz
kurz über Verhandlungen nachzudenken
also wir fragen noch mal warum wird
dieses System verhindert glauben sie ist
das eine Angst
vor warnte sehr früh vor einem Atomkrieg
eine
atomareneskalation ist das eine Sorge
davor dass wenn Putin tatsächlich äh
gehen müsste dass dann Russland zerfiele
und so ein Chaos nach einem Sturz von
Putin was glauben sie steckt dahinter
was offensichtlich in Teilen eben glaube
das die Antwort viel simpler ist okay
wir haben ja lange über den Lieferung
der unterschiedlichen Panzertypen
diskutiert dann wurde es geliefert das
hat der Bundeskanzler als botmäßig
empfunden dann kamen weitere Wünsche
dann kam wieder eine Diskussion ich
glaube schlicht dass er es nicht will
weil er nicht will also das mag jetzt
etwas profan sein aber manche
Entscheidungen manche Entscheidungen
sind wirklich auf einem Niveau ich habe
ihn ja auch gefragt bei der
bundeswehrtagung ob es eine Strategie
gibt was machen wir eigentlich und
reagieren eben nicht nur auf Wünsche das
gerade gesagtock wenn man sie vertreten
diese Regierung also ich mE wenn Sie
heute sagen der deutsche Bundeskanzler
will einfach nicht jetzt das ist doch
das kann doch
ja aber ich bin sicher dass sie auch was
Frau vonlein betrifft nicht alles gut
finden was sie macht und das ist auch
ihre Kollegin die ukra K
unterstütz ich wollte ih nur sagen wir
wollen jetzt gar nicht ablenken von der
Situation ich bin in Abgeordnete ich
kann den Kanzler meine Kolleginnen
Kollegen übrigens auch durchaus
Sozialdemokraten grüne und wir wir
können ihn immer nur bitten aber als
letztes Wort hat der Kanzler hat der
Kanzler das Wort das können wir jetzt
komisch finden oder nicht aber darum
geht es nicht sondern es geht darum das
offensichtlich die Einschätzung jetzt
sind wir bei der berühmten roten Linie
da wird ja oft drüber gesprochen also
diese Eskalationsstufe angehört ich
halte das für Unsinn weil wir auf der
anderen Seite sehen und da lösen wir uns
mal gerade von Europa nämlich die
Tatsache dass ja Putin auch anfängt mit
dem Feuer zu spielen was die NATO
betrifft wenn wir hier plötzlich
russisches Kampfflugzeug abfangen über
der Ostsee oder eine vor kurzem
ferngelenkte Rakete gezielt quasi ein
Schlenker um um Territorium Polens macht
um dann in der Ukraine zu treffen sind
das ja Werkzeuge um mal zu gucken was
macht eigentlich die NATO wann reagiert
sie oder lassen wir das zu und deswegen
ist dieses Signal so wichtig und wir
diskutieren ja nicht im luftleeren Raum
Wladimir Putin bekommt das alles mit das
wird auch auf von der russischen
deutschen Botschaft in Russland
bestätigt das heißt die Gefahr ist dass
er sich ja schon darauf stützt
möglicherweise auch die die berühmte
Brücke über die über die sehr viel
geliefert wird aber eben nicht nur weil
er natürlich fragt wenn die das jetzt
doch machen was passiert da nicht das
ist ja wie ein großes Schachspiel und
deswegen die eisenbahnlen sind ja schon
gebaut sozusagen auf also so ist es und
es gibt auch Wasserwege also es gibt ja
Möglichkeiten alternativ und wissen Sie
dieser Krieg ist ja komplett transparent
in ein ein ein ein ein solcher Krieg ist
komplett aufklärbar wir können genau
sehen diese endlosdebatte über die
Panzer führte dazu dass die Russen über
hunderte Kilometer
Gräben prall gefüllt mit mit mit
Munition bzw mit geut haben wir hier
schon viel drüber gesprochen sie sagen
der Kanzler tut das weil er es tut Herr
Sauer letzte Frage in der Sache haben
sie irgendeinen anderen eine andere
Erklärung was der Grund sein könnte kaum
aber ich meine ich kann mir vorstellen
dass es einfach Teile der SPD gibt für
die das absolut inakzeptabel ist und
dass darauf rücks sich genommen sehr
nachvollziehbar es geht also um die
innerparteilichen Spannungen und nicht
um die Notwendigkeiten die Europa jetzt
eigentlich bruchte in was wirklich
rätselhaft ist an dieser ganzen Thematik
ist dann eben doch dass man sagt man
kann ja entscheiden wir möchten den
Taurus nicht der Ukraine geben okay
warum sind die nicht nachbestellt für
die Bundeswehr ja dass man einfach sagt
wir haben dann zumindest mal so viele
wie wir eigentlich brauchen nach
natovorgabe für den Fall dass der ganz
schlimme Fall eintritt und wir uns
selbst verteidigen müssen als Bündnis
das ist ja auch nicht geschehen warum
wenn man sagt wir wollen eigentlich gar
nicht dass sie den Taurus bekommen weil
der Taurus eben vermeintlich so speziell
ist ja
was warum hat man dann nicht im
Kanzleramt gesagt ha wir kommen jetzt
auf die Idee mit diesem Ringtausch der
nicht stattfindet aber es war mal eine
Idee und dann maggeln wir eben mit den
Briten genusowas aus indem wir den dahin
geben und dann bekommen die Ukrainer
eben mehr Storm Shadow und Skalp also
die Idee müsste doch sein hauptsache die
Ukrainer bekommen am Ende das was Sie
brauchen aber all die Sachen passieren
ja auch nicht und das sind schon Dinge
die ich wirklich da doch auch
kritikwürdig finde sie sind Frau
Schröder natürlich auch nicht nicht nur
Beobachterin alessen was da passiert
sondern sie haben auch eine persönliche
Meinung als Bürger was glauben Sie wie
lange macht das auch eine Bevölkerung
noch mit die jetzt sieht okay wir sind
da jetzt bald im dritten Jahr dieses
Krieges die sieht wie hoch der Preis ist
den wir dafür bezahlen die sieht welche
höheren Forderungen in Sachen
Verteidigung auf dieses Europa auf die
Welt zukommen will wenn sie sich vor
Putin schützen will was glauben Sie wie
lange haben wir die Bevölkerung hat Frau
Stck Zimmermann im Europawahlkampf ich
weiß gar nicht wie sie das schaffen wird
die Menschen davon zu überzeugen die
haben Angst GI no andere wichtige Themen
über die wir gerne diskutieren können
wenn
sie genau so also wie lange geht es noch
gut ist die kurzgestellte
Frage die Zahlen im letzten Jahr waren
ja ganz interessant da war die
Zustimmung für eine starke Erhöhung des
Verteidigungsbudgets bei paar 6% das war
sehr viel ein Drittel war dagegen in
diesem Jahr weiß ich es nicht aber die
Frage ist bei sowas immer eine Frage der
politischen Kommunikation was kann
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern in Deutschland
zugetraut werden ist ja eine eine Frage
die auch selten gestellt wird genauso
wie die Frage nach der politischen
Strategie die hinter der Ukraine steht
weil manchmal der Eindruck entsteht dass
in Deutschland den Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern relativ wenig an Wandel
zugetraut wird relativ wenig an an Last
zugetraut wird und häufig versucht wird
in irgendeiner Form äh zu kaschieren
dass wir in eine Welt reinlaufen in der
wir wirklich mit Problemen umgehen
müssen die übereinander liegen die
nebeneinander liegen und die auf Dauer
gestellt sind wir sind ja ganz
ungewöhnlich in eine Lage gerutscht die
nicht mit so sequentiellen Krisen erst
der eine Krieg dann der nächste Krieg
dann der dritte Krieg dann die
Klimakrise passiert die sind alle
gleichzeitig alle auf Dauer gestellt und
alle sehr sehr teuer und werden uns als
Bürgerinnen und Bürger hier in
Deutschland sehr viel abverlangen und
ich sehe noch nicht die politische
Kommunikation die das wirklich auf den
Tisch legt ich sehe aber bei den Bürger
mit denen wir beispielsweise in Hamburg
gesprochen haben in
forschungswerkstätten sehe ich dass das
Wissen um diese notwendige Veränderung
da ist und ich spreche nicht nur von
Verteidigungspolitik ich spreche auch
von transformationspolitik gegenüber der
Klimakrise ich spreche von der Krise der
Demokratie wir haben die antifd
Demonstration gerade auf den Straßen
gesehen alle Menschen verstehen hier
wandelt sich gerade eine Weltordnung
eine europäische Ordnung und wir müssen
uns verdammt warm anziehen das würde ich
gerne in der politischen Kommunikation
sehen und wir sind das ist natürlich
hoch interessant wir sind in der
Situation in Bezug auf Putin Klaus gar
nicht mehr zu glauben dass er nicht
weiter aufrüsten könnte dass er nicht
weiter Soldaten an diese grauenhafte
Front schicken würde und ih
Menschenleben eigentlich egal sind
sondern wir wissen auch dass er auf
Trump warten wollte und dafür sicherlich
viel Atem hat aber er bräuchte ihn gar
nicht mal weil auch so sieht es für
Putin nicht schlecht aus aus also das
hat jetzt natürlich viele militärische
Aspekte für die ich nicht der Experte
bin ähm auf Trump kann lange lange
warten dass das ist die gute Nachricht
Trump wird die Wahlen nicht gewinnen ah
okay ähm und das sagt hier einer der am
Abend der Wahl 2016 hat das ZDF seine
Reporter alle auf der Welt verpflichtet
ganz kurz zu zeigen wen sie denken
Hillary oder oder Trump und ich war
einer von zweien der andere war Johannes
hanno der eine Trump statie hochgehalten
hat weil ich gebranntes Kind war von
brexit Entscheidung paar Monate vorher
in London und die Atmosphäre in London
damals und die Gespräche mit Menschen
auf der Straße in in Washington waren so
verdammt
ähnlich aber die Amerikaner werden den
nicht zum zweiten Mal wählen wir sollten
uns nicht irritieren l nein interessant
ähm das im Moment ist das völlig falsche
Bild entstanden durch diese Vorwahlen
die immer die Extremisten in den
Parteien gefördert haben das liegt in
dem System das ist immer so dass die
Eiferer das Wort haben wenn es nach den
Playoffs dann im Spätsommer dazu kommt
dass die ersten Amerikaner sich Gedanken
über die Frage machen wer soll
eigentlich Präsident werden wird die
Mehrheit nicht Trump wieder wähen ist
meine vorh das ist mal ein das ist mal
wirklich also es gibt ein tiefes
Luftholen hier am Tisch und dann fragen
wir uns vielleicht trotzdem eine Sekunde
was das bedeuten würde wenn die These
von Klaus nicht wahr wird
Donald Trump will in die erste Reihe
damals 2017 beim natogipfel genauso wie
jetzt im Wahlkampf um die
US-Präsidentschaft Krieg in der Ukraine
für Trump kein
Problem ich würde den Krieg innerhalb
von 24 Stunden beenden eine einfache
Sache der Vorwahlkampf bietet Trump die
Bühne für eine Politik auf die Europa
immer noch keine Antwort hat Beispiel
die
NATO nur wenn sie sich uns gegenüber
richtig verhält die Nato hat uns
ausgenutzt die Europäer haben unseren
militärischen Schutz genommen und wir
haben drauf gezahlt ich habe ihnen
damals gesagt wenn ihr nicht zahlt dann
werden wir euch nicht mehr
beschützen ja KUS also für den Fall dass
das Unwahrscheinliche Eintritt und Trump
äh gewählt würde was passiert dann ja
die schlechte Nachricht von nachdem ich
gesagt hate Trump wird nicht gewählt ist
dass es darauf nicht ankommt äh diese
amerikanische Forderung dass Europa
endlich mal sich um seine eigenen
Probleme kümmert das ist ein
europäisches Problem und die Zeiten sind
vorbei wo sich ein amerikanischer
Präsident Clinton hinsetzt mit
Schautafeln und den Leuten erklärt
weshalb Amerika wegen der Flüchtlings
Ströme in Europa ein Interesse dran hat
den Kosovokrieg militärisch niedrig zu
halten die sind vorbei so da auch mit
einem beiden sind die vorbei weil der
Kongress nicht mehr mitmacht also der
Unterschied in in Sachen Rüstung und
natozukunft und so weiter ist leider
nicht so groß wie man
wie man meinen würde wir müssen uns war
anziehen wo wird der Bundeskanzler ins
weize Haus zu Joe Biden gehen fahren
fliegen Gott sei Dank mit dem Rückhalt
von Entscheidung heute mit dem Rückhalt
von dieser Entscheidung heute wofür
beiden sicherlich sehr dankbar ist weil
auch das wieder ein Signal in die
Republikaner hinein sein dürfte
dieser Draht wird nicht mehr da sein
dieser dann jetzt bessere Draht zwischen
Berlin und Washington
der wird sicher weiterhin ein guter
Draht sein aber die Aufgabenstellung
verändert sich und deshalb ist das was
sie gerade sagten Frau Schröder dass die
öffentliche Debatte in Deutschland sich
auf diese neuen Zeiten einstellen müssen
wir haben das ja erlebt nach der
zeitenwenderede des Kanzlers
und nach dem anzaltritt von pistius
Pistorius und seinen Erklärungen da dass
die Bereitschaft da ist diese
Verantwortung zu übernehmen was im
Moment nicht wirklich genutzt wird von
der Politik es wird immer noch so getan
als soll ob man den Kindern die Wahrheit
nicht sagen mus als würde sich in
unserem Leben nichts ändern Herr
trotzdem noch mal die Frage in 24
Stunden will Donald Trump diesen Krieg
dieses Problem
lösen wie dankbar wird kieev dafür sein
ja ist die Frage wie die Lösung aussieht
ja also ich wä natürlich froh wenn in 24
Stunden das Problem gelöst wäre aber ich
meine wir kennen ja den Herrn Trump
jetzt auch ein Weilchen und er sagt eben
manches was mit der Realität nicht viel
zu tun hat ja aber ich eine Ergänzung
ist fairerweise zu machen Trump hat
diese Äußerung mehrfach getan es gibt
mindestens ein interviewerer woer ein
bisschen nachgefragt wurde wie zum
Teufel willst du das machen in 24
Stunden mhm und da hat er dann gesagt
ich würde zu zelenski sagen pass auf
junge du musst jetzt mal einsehen ihr
könnt diesen Krieg nicht restlos
gewinnen du musst auf gewisse Dinge
verzichten dann rede ich mit Putin Land
gegen Frieden z.B das hat er nicht
ausbuschabiert und dann rede ich mit
Putin und sag und du musst auf deinen
Angriffskrieg verzichten und wenn du
nicht verzichtest dann werde ich
selenski so aufrüsten dass du nichts
anderes mehr machen kannst so das ist ja
schon ich meine das ist jetzt auch
geträumt das ist nicht realistische
Politik aber es ist ein bisschen mehr
als diese blöde Behauptung in 24 Stunden
habe ich das geregelt wir sind also wir
erinnern uns auch noch was Herr Trump
mit dem mit Herr Kim Jong Un in
Nordkorea alles vorhte und so weiter und
was ist daraus geworden gar nichts
Frieden Z wel lügt einfach Danke und
auch Putin kann sich wahrscheinlich
nicht wirklich über einen
unberechenbaren Präsidenten im White
House freuen oder würden Sie sagen die
machen tatsächlich dann gemeinsame Sache
Putin und Trump na ja Trump ist ja quasi
unberechenbar aus Absicht es soll ja
unberechenbar sein was gesagt wird es
soll ja auch unklar sein was gemacht
wird und das macht natürlich für Putin
auch schwer schätze ich mal sich darauf
einzustellen was die amerikanische
Strategie ist es ist ja für uns genauso
ist ist in Europa genauso schwer man
muss sich auf unterschiedlichste
Szenarien vorbereiten falls er doch
gewählt werden sollte weil man nicht
weiß was davon ernst gemeint ist was
davon wieder sich verändern wird wo ein
rückzier machen wird und wo nicht und
das das macht es gefährlich und diese
Vorbereitungen sind halt notwendig zur
Zeit und jetzt sind wir mit der Politik
genau da wo wir vorhin schon waren
nämlich zu fragen hat Europa Frau
stckzimmermann Frau vonderlein hat
Europa diese trumpfreien Jahre gut
genutzt aus ihrer Sicht hat Frau
vonderlein hat Europa definitiv nicht
gut genutzt und und zunächst muss man
eines noch mal festhalten wenn Trump
sagt kümmert euch um unsere Aufgaben hat
er recht einfach mal sagen wir haben hab
auch so Gefühl immer in Europa dass wir
dann schmunzeln wenn Trump was sagt aber
in der Sache hat er recht es werden
nicht dauerhaft 330 Millionen Amerikaner
400 Millionen Europäer verteidigen das
wird nicht funktionieren und deswegen
müssen wir jetzt uns auf die Hinterfüße
Stellen Frage in diesem europawahlah
sein wie kann Europa weiter Frieden
garantieren das größte versprechen
Europas Frieden zu garantieren und das
werden wir nur schaffen wenn wir jetzt
Kräfte bündeln und da bin ich dann schon
etwas auch ratlos dass wenn dann in
Deutschland 100 Milliarden ausgegebt
wird man nach europäischen Projekten
schon lange suchen muss wenn man sich
das anschaut wo wird also jetzt
europäisch investiert wo gehen wir
wirklich mit Europa voran beispielsweise
Cyber Defense wo wir kaum Grenzen haben
keine Grenzen mehr haben oder bei MLE
Defense Kaliningrad sind
raketenstationiert die in wenigen
Minuten Warschau Berlin und Kopenhagen
erreichen können wir brauchen
europäischen raketenschutzschirm jetzt
der auch europäisch gedacht und gemacht
wird damit wir zukünftig eben nicht mehr
in Israel oder in Amerika bitten müssen
die Technologie bereitzustellen reden
wir gleich sondern wir eigenständig
entscheiden können und diese Projekte
wir machen jetzt mühsam Fortschritte
dass wir bisschen Vorankommen aber die
Bereitschaft der Mitgliedstaaten
voranzugehen ist nicht da und ich würde
mir wünschen dass heute ein Emmanuel
macron und der Olaf Scholz das machen
was Kohl mit der gemacht haben beim Euro
jetzt sagen da ist morgen da müssen wir
jetzt hin und es heißt jetzt den
Einstieg in der europäische aber Herr
Weber das Problem ist ja schon länger
wir haben 2014 den ersten Angriff Putins
gab wo wir kollektiv geschwiegen und
weggeschaut haben das war ja die
Generalprobe dessen was jetzt gerade
passiert und Europa hätte in den letzten
Jahren natürlich was machen können und
die kommissionspräsidentin Ursula
vonlein war 6 Jahre
Verteidigungsministerin sie kennt sich
also aus in diesem Bereich da hätte ja
mal aus der Kommission auch mal die
Initiative ergriffen werden dieser
Projekte los diese Projekte loszutreten
das ist Pass dass wir in dem Bereich
leider Gottes die Einstimmigkeit haben
das hat unsktorade
wierfüt müs dieion soark machen cheiden
kann und m am Ende der Tage Europa
erstmal braucht die Kommission jemand
der sich ausschließlich mit dem Thema
europäische Sicherheit beschäftigt ich
bin der Meinung wir brauchen in Europa
eine andere Außenpolitik das heißt auch
wegzukommen von dieser von diesem
geographischen Blick des jeweiligen
Landes wir sind eben alle fürinander
verantwortlich und auch Deutschland kann
sich nicht in der Mitte wohlfühlen und
egal sein was im Süden Spaniens Südens
Italiens oder Osten Griechenlands
passiert ich glaube das ist eine große
Möglichkeit auch für das parlamentm
diesem Thema intensiv zu beschäftigen
und zwar schneller als wir gucken können
weil wir überhaupt keine Alternative
haben ich würde gerne noch einen Satz
sagen weil ich sehr viele sehr viel mit
wirklich jungen Leuten auch an
Universitäten zusammenkommen die in den
2000ern geboren sind und die sind alle
hochalarmiert weil die in eine Welt
geboren sind jetzt mit Studium mit
Ausbildung sie kennen das da wird dann
gesagt wo machst du dein Master ja ich
bin in Mailand ich bin in Florenz auch
ich war in Oslo bzw in einem in einem
EU-Staat also wo das mit völliger
Selbstverständlichkeit gesagt wird und
diese Generation merkt jetzt da droht
etwas wegzubrechen es ist also nicht nur
die Generation meiner Generation die das
Glück hatte in dieses immer friedlichere
Europa reinzuwachsen und das macht mir
wiederum Mut eben diesen ein diesen
Menschen diesen jungen Menschen eine
Möglichkeit zu geben und wir müssen da
beinhart reagieren weil wir sonst in
einer anderen Welt Aufwachen wir sind
wahrscheinlich in dieser anderen Welt
schon hat die Bundesregierung Frau Stck
zimmermann auch schon Strategien Pläne
ich rede von der deutschen Regierung der
sie angehören für diese zweite trumpzeit
gibt es Strategien wie man dann
Verfahren wird also es gibt natürlich
hinter den Kulissen gibt es natürlich
Pläne wir reden jetzt nicht von
militärischen aber wir reden natürlich
von Finanzwirtschaft die sich natürlich
Gedanken machenemse richtig
Schuldenbremse wird Schuldenbremse hat
dam ihr Lieblingsthema in der FDP aber
es würde das ist nicht das
Lieblingsthema das ist für die deutschen
das Lieblingsthema wenn wir nämlich
anfangen würde
wen sie dann kommt natürlich ich sage
gleich Notfall und weil sie genau an
dieser Stelle schon einen Notfall
formuliert haben das heißt die Ampel hat
sich schon mit sich selbst und das
geschieht nicht so häufig darauf
verständigt was die Ausnahme von der
Schuldenbremse ist eine neue Situation
in Russland das ist ja ganz klar
formuliert also letztendlich wenn unser
Land angegriffen wird dann haben wir
andere Debatten dann debattieren wir
nicht mehr über Bildung oder anderes
dann wird es um das Überleben gehen und
wenn sie mir noch Einsatz erlauben und
da wde es auch relevant sein Herr Weber
ich schaue jetzt sie nicht persönlich an
sondern auch die CDU CSU ich glaube bei
solchen elementaren Themen wo es also um
die Sicherheit die äußere und damit auch
um die innere Sicherheit Deutschlands
geht ist es wirklich von großer
Bedeutung dass wir versuchen an einem
Strang zu ziehen weil das kann man
Menschen draußen jetzt nicht erklären
wir haben glaube ich die gleiche
Einschätzung unterschiedliche Antworten
aber letztendlich glaube ich übrigens
auch in Europa dass diese groß Themen
auch deswegen gemeinsam gelöst werden
müssen be aller Unterschiedlichkeit
müssen sie vorangen das weil wir keine
Ränder mehr haben von Rechten und
Hardcore linken die nämlich absolut
Moskau treu sind wenn sie die AFD
anhören wenn Sie Frau Wagenknecht
anhören da fällt ihnen nichts mehr ein
dass da wird diese politische Linie über
die wir gerade gesprochen haben völlig
anders gesehen worüber reden wir gerade
wir reden darüber wie die Politik wie
die Ampel eine Bevölkerung die nicht auf
den Kopf gefallen ist darauf vorbereitet
vielleicht 2% nicht reichen sondern dass
wir 3 und 4% brauchten für deswen ist
die mittelfristige Finanzplanung wird
genau darauf gemünst sein und das wird
letztlich bedeuten dass manche Dinge
anders finanziert werden müssen weil
das Bundesregierung muss jetzt sagen das
macht die Bundesregierung gerade nicht
mit diesem Haushalt wir wollen ja einmal
ganz kurz wir holen uns ganz kurz noch
mal dann gibt's den Streit bei Herrn
sauer die Erklärung dafür abholen was
eigentlich passieren müsste für diese 2%
das erreichen wir ja gerade in diesem
Haushalt der just dieser Woche Morgen
verabschiedet worden werden hier ist
mein schneller Satz er ist auch kurz
erzählt wer das Kindergeld für die
soldatenväter mit reingerechnet damit
wir auf die 2% kommen wie gut ist diesem
dieser Bevölkerung zu erklären dass noch
mehr Geld für Verteidigung und noch
weniger Geld für sozialen Ausgleich den
Klimawandel für alles weitere zu
vorhanden ist also die Konstruktion ist
ja so dass dieses 100 Milliarden Euro
Sondervermögen existiert und wenn man
diese 100 Milliarden dazu rechnet dann
sind die 2% erreicht ist dieses
Sondervermögen allerdings aufgebraucht
ab 20 26 27 dann kann man sich das so
vorstellen dass diese gesamte
Veranstaltung Finanzierung der
Verteidigung quasi von der Klippe fällt
ja dann gibt es ein riesiges Delta eine
Kluft zwischen dem was man grundsätzlich
im Haushalt hat und dem was man jetzt
mit diesen 100 Milliarden quasi ausgeben
konnte oben drüber und natürlich Kosten
all diese Dinge die jetzt beschafft
werden F35 Kampfjets aus den USA und so
weiter und so fort auch eine Menge Geld
im Unterhalt und das muss eben
finanziert werden das heißt die
Bundeswehr geht jetzt gerade auf eine
Situation zu in der sie im Prinzip im
vollkommen finanziellen stillstand ist
und man gerade genug Geld hat den Laden
so am Laufen zu halten also jetzt muss
so und und so und jetzt ist sozusagen
der Punkt ist ich glaube was man den
Menschen und ich halte das für überhaupt
gar keine schwierige politische
Herausforderung was weil das zeigen die
Daten zum einen wenn man guckt wie ist
die Einstellung äh der Bevölkerung zur
Bundeswehr wie beurteilen die Menschen
die Sicherheitslage in Europa wie ist
die Solidarität mit der Ukraine ich
mache mir da ehrlich gesagt keine großen
Sorgen ich finde das ist eigentlich in
Deutschland bis auf die würde ich sagen
bisschen verrückten Ränder eine ziemlich
stabile Angelegenheit und das merkt man
auch im anekdotischen ja so die Menschen
sagen im Prinzip ja gut wenn wir eine
Bundeswehr haben wir also wir wir
brauchen offensichtlich eine dann sollte
die auch funktionieren das heißt man
kann das glaube ich kommunizieren und
man kann den Leuten sagen 2% ist die
Vorgabe und das machen wir jetzt mal
europäische Verteidigung ist hier
annotiert worden wir sind immer noch
Frau Schröder mit 27 ich formuliere es
saloppp wasserköpfen ausgestattet mit
verschiedensten Waffensystemen innerhalb
Europas wie groß wäre der der die
Bewegung die in Europa stattfinden
müsste in diesem politisch beschriebenen
Europa um wirklich eine europäische
Armee aufzustellen da wird kurz
aufgelacht ja die europäische Armee das
ist auch so ein ein ein Projekt das es
schon sehr lange
gibt weder die europäische Armee wird
kommen noch eine Person die in der
Europäischen Kommission für Sicherheit
zuständig ist außerhalb kleinerer
Programme noch eine
europäische Rüstungsindustrie die ein
europäisches rüstungsprodukt
zusammenbaut weil die Regularien der
Europäischen Union das nicht zulassen im
im Rüstungssektor ist es ja klar da gibt
es ja da gibt es bestimmte
ökonomische Probleme die dahinter liegen
warum manche von diesen Großprojekten
wie fgas oder so nicht gut funktionieren
die Kommission hat relativ wenig
Einfluss auf sicherheitspolitische
Fragen weil Einstimmigkeit und anderer
politikbereicht und das wird sich nicht
ändern wenn es nicht eine Reform der
politischen Institutionen der
Europäischen Union gibt es geht nicht so
um das klein klein sondern es geht darum
schaffen wir man wagt es kaum zu sagen
eine Vertragsveränderung schaffen
mehcheidung es liegt schon so lange auf
dem Tisch qualifizierte
Mehrheitsentscheidungen in der außen und
Sicherheitspolitik liegen schon seit
Jahren auf dem Tisch aber unter anderen
Vorbedingung unter anderen Vorbedingung
andere Situation haben eine andere
Situation aber es wäre etwas was lösbar
wäre es gibt viele Herausforderungen die
sind nicht gut lösbar diese eine
Herausforderung kann man hätten wir den
Schutz herr Weber nicht mehr den wir von
den USA haben gesetzt den Fall Trump
würde vielleicht auch dazu greifen den
atomschirm einzuklappen uns in der NATO
eben nicht mehr die gekannte Hilfe und
Unterstützung zu
gewähren was denken sie würde Europa
dann tun ich f an wir haben 80% der
militärischen Kraft der NATO sind
außerhalb der EU ist die Vereinigten
Staaten die Türkei Großbritannien die
haben echtes Militär wenn man es mal so
nennen darf das heißt wir sind als
Europäer heute nackt in einer Welt von
Stürmen wir sind nackt in einer Welt von
Stürmen
und und und in der Situation Ringen wir
seit Jahr um die Fragestellung ob wir
jetzt in Europa endlich Vorankommen wir
würden Milliarden an Geldern sparen wenn
wir gemeinsam die Rüstung beschaffen
würden wir haben 17 verschiedene
panzerarten die Amerikaner haben eine
wir haben 180 verschiedene Waffensysteme
die Amerikaner haben 30 Systeme wir
würden ihres Geld sparen der
Steuerzahler Geld sparen W
Effizienzgewinne hinkriegen wenn wir das
machen deswegen meine Partei wird dafür
kämpfen jetzt den europäischen Pfeiler
der Verteidigung aufzubauen und ich sag
ausdrücklich dazu das ist nichts neues
in der Geschichte Europas war nämlich
Adenauer CDU meine Partei CDU CSU hatte
damals die urgründung der Idee Europa
auf dem Weg zu bringen war die
Verteidigungsunion und französischen
französischen nationalzusammen
gescheitert ist aber die Idee dass die
dass man das einch mal einordnet die
Idee dass wir uns gemeinsam bewaffnen
verteidigen ist nichts Bedrohliches
sondern zunächst mal das Versprechen
damals war es das Versprechen in Europa
wird nie wieder Krieg geben wir schaffen
das gemeinsam rauszugehen und ich sag
wenn es noch mal bisschen über den
Tellerand des ukrainekriegs auch
rausschauen wir fliehen der aus Afrika
aus Mali alle ziehen sich zurück die
Franzosen die deutschen jeder zieht sich
zurück die
Wagner ke wenn die dortige Regierung uns
nicht mehr will gehen
wir will ich will deutlich machen dass
wir dorten Verantwortung die wir nicht
mehr tragen können aus guten
nachvollziehbaren Gründen ja derzeit
abgeben und andere Kräfte das übernehmen
wir haben Kabul nicht mehr im Kopf
erinnern wir uns an Kabul wie wir alle
geflohen sind weil die Amerikaner weil
die Amerikaner nicht bereit waren den
Abzug ordentlich zu organisieren wir
Europäer sind nicht mehr bereit aus
Kabul ordentlichen Abzug zu organisieren
und ich s auch und ich sag auch dazu ich
sag auch dazu wir hätten wir hätten bei
der bei den bei wenn wir Israel reden
haben die Amerikaner deswegen Einfluss
weil sie zwei Flugzeugträger
dortthinschicken wir als Europäer haben
das nicht deswegen ist es jetzt dringend
notwendig dass Europa dorten gemeinsam
in dieser Welt draußen auftritt und ich
sag und ich sag das liegt derzeit daran
wie sie es beschrieben haben dass wir
die Einstimmigkeit haben dass es nur
vorangeht bei diesen Themenfelder wenn
alle 27 dafür sind deswegen brauchen wir
die vertragsreform wir müssen das Thema
anpacken europa muss sich selbstverte
zum Initiativrecht des Parlamentes es
auch nicht gibt europäische Verteidigung
Ihre Frage war ja was passiert wenn die
nuklearen Sicherheitsgarantien
zurückgezogen werden und ich will das
auch noch mal explizit sagen ich ertappe
mich in letzter Zeit immer wieder dabei
dass ich bestimmte Dinge sage die hätte
ich vor 5 Jahren auch für vollkommen
unmöglich gehalten ja und auch
Nuklearwaffen sind nun wahrlich nichts
was ich mir in großer Menge Wünsche im
Gegenteil ich habe eigentlich die
letzten 20 Jahre meines Lebens mit
verbracht zu überlegen wie wer mit die
Dinger los aber wenn das passieren
sollte dass auch diese nuklearen
Sicherheitsgarantien wegfallen dann wird
es richtig düster weil die Dinge die wir
schon längst hätten tun müssen z.B ein
Zugehen auf den Herrn Präsident macron
der 2020 schon die Tür ein Spalt
aufgemacht hat zu sagen lasst uns einen
strategischen Dialog führen wie wir das
in Europa gemeinsam organisieren der
jetzt diese Woche noch mal diese Tür
weiter aufgemacht hat da müssten wir
dann im Prinzip durch diese Tür im
Vollsprint durchlaufen und ein sehr
diffizile komplexe politische Materie
gemeinsam durchackern und dann werden
wir noch lange nicht mal ansatzweise
wenn wir uns als Europa um Frankreich da
gruppieren würden an dem Punkt an dem
wir heute sind also das will ich nur
noch mal in den Raum stellen da könnten
noch sehr viel schlimmere Dinge uns ins
Haus stehen muss ich leider ih wiprechen
was ich ungern tue weil das eine ist das
mit den Franzosen möglich aufzugehen wir
haben auch noch Großbritannien ganz
wichtig es ist mehr als die EU diese
Frage aber im Vergleich zu dem was die
Amerikaner uns an Schutz bieten sind die
Franzosen weit dahinter und die Frage
ist würde in einem Fall der Falle
Frankreich für Deutschland da sein ja
weil Frankreich will keine Russen am
rehein stehen haben aber was ist in der
Ferne was ist im Baltikum absolut das
sie wiedersprechen mir gar nicht das ist
genau mein Punkt deswegen sage ich ist
es so unfassbar schwierig das sind dann
extrem diffizile militärpolitische
äh Dinge die dann da äh besprochen
werden müssten und dann geht's dann
unter Umständen auch um ein
fähigkeitsausbau weil das
nukleardispositiv Frankreich so wie es
jetzt existiert wäre nicht geeignet um
eine erweiterte abstchreckung für den
Rest Europas nukleardispositiv merke ich
mir und